what is the whole beef with the storm
the capital thing like why is this even
an issue I wouldn't say it's a beep I
would just say we should recognize that
there were obviously Asian provocateurs
who were involved in the stormy not
saying they caused it but they
definitely helped instigate some of the
violence that's almost 100 that's
basically verified so in agent
provocateur for anybody watching at home
this is me yeah
for anybody's natural an agent
provocateur is someone who is working
with the government an agent of the
state or of at least of authority who is
trying to take a volatile situation and
turn it worse for example more violent
let's say it's a black lives matter
protest that's right they're walking
down the street there might be an
undercover FBI agent who takes a brick
throws it through a glass window say
that it's Minnesota and a guy has a mask
on and there's an umbrella that he
happens to be holding and that he
happens to crack open a window which
then is the Looting of Target which
leads to the burning down of a police
station and then nobody knows who this
umbrella man is and then it turns out
that he might be a white nationalist and
he might be connected actually in some
way to the state but hey this is all
speculation it's not like that would
never happen so you're saying that that
happened in January 6th yeah
and probably at every anti-establishment
protest that's like ever and what is the
advantage of that that you get to squash
the protest because it's turned violent
well now why does the state want yes
because not only do they squash the
protests the capital police despite the
fact that they [__] up got over a
billion dollars in new funding not that
many people were fired they were hailed
as Heroes the National Guard spent
billions of dollars basically I was in
DC at this time it was the green zone
from Baghdad there were literal National
Guard Humvees all up and down the
streets the capital is fenced off
getting it this is the People's Building
it's supposed to be one of the Hallmarks
of it was almost anybody would be able
to walk in there as long as you're just
getting wanted now it's like full-blown
like suicide bomber level security all
over we shouldn't forget either that in
January 2021 there were a lot of
democratic calls for beefing up like a
new Patriot Act Like 2.0 complete
expansion of the surveillance State they
were going after my favorite was the New
York Times if you want to find this um
where they talked about how we need to
crack it's like New York Times uh
encryption January 6. basically they
were writing about why they need to go
after signal like encrypted messages
because people who had used um
let's find it yeah uh if you just want
to look like yeah New York Times
encryption January 6 I believe it was
written by Kevin Roos and it's about
it's basically about how social is an
app that is encrypted messages they're
like why we shouldn't have encryption
and it's the reason the reason case they
were making was well it was used by
people on January 6. I'm like yeah but
people have encrypted
encrypted right right I mean the Twitter
files obviously a good example of this
too the point being that it opened up
room in the elite conversation for
expanding the national security
surveillance state in a way that we
haven't seen in literally since the Iraq
War the BLM riots were actually a good
example too we have uh we had someone on
our show uh specifically about a
informant and agent provocateur who was
inside I believe of the Portland BLM
riots who directly was instigating like
actual violence and all of this has come
out in court documents that have been
and part of the reason why I also think
I kind of have to uh May a Culp of
myself is I covered a lot of this stuff
whenever it was on terrorism so I
remember I would my early career was all
writing about Isis and terrorism and I
remember reading some of these court
documents and it'd be like the FBI made
contact with this man 18 year old after
he tweeted Allahu Akbar and they were
like hey man how's it going you want to
go to Syria and he was like yeah I want
to go to Syria and he go is you should
steal your money and buy a ticket on
your mom's credit card to Syria and I'll
meet you at the airport and he's like
okay sure and then the moment that you
show up at the airport they have you on
a material support for terrorism charge
and you're going to jail for like 20
years well that's a great Point that's
exactly that's the point But at the time
we were like well it's right on the edge
but well he's an Isis but if it's that
effective shouldn't we hadn't trap more
of them well okay that's the FBI's
argument right but like civil rights
this man is born in Ohio he's an
American citizen did he get entrapped
because if he did that's actually
illegal is he right yeah see there we go
no but that's the point is whenever it
was Muslims most of us were willing to
look the other other way and be like oh
this the FBI is like their argument was
well this is the way that we prevent any
would-be suicide bombers and you're like
yeah
this is what we should do but you know
how like uh like uh uh [__] release
their DMS with famous people like you
know like oh [__] LeBron DM me and
they post it that's what the FBI should
do with these people who are willing to
go to Syria right like don't arrest them
but just these people are idiots
he was supposed to go to Syria who knows
and they just let the community take
care of it and then the shame thing
works that would be more Justice
think about like do you guys know about
the aggression we want to go to Syria
okay yes that's a predator dudes just
like that yeah
they'll be like hey you should shoot up
the police station and you should go buy
a gun and then I'll come and meet you
the moment you buy the gun boom they got
you on weapons charge they got you on
your messages you plead guilty you're
going to jail for like a decade
um if you want to look up the Gretchen
Whitmer case the number oh yes this is a
perfect example I mean there are more
feds involved in the case than actual
defendants
FBI kidnapping plot which would never
have happened if they weren't like hey
we should kidnap them yeah they're like
you should kidnap the governor he's like
no I don't want to like yeah but you
should meet this guy and he'll help you
with it you're like no but I don't
really want to be like no but you really
should do it no they talk to the other
guy you're like hey you should meet this
guy he wants to kidnap the governor he's
like but I don't really want to and then
I mean and it all comes out and you're
like there are more feds involved in
this that you got the gun they broke FBI
informant that's the other part A lot of
these guys are just Lawless like the way
that they act
um oh my other favorite one Mark if you
want to find is about the number of
crimes that FBI confidential informants
have been allowed to commit it's like
thousands of known crimes as in like
people who are confidential informants
yeah there it is allowed informants to
commit 5
000 crimes according to the FBI's own
internal data so they're like you sign
up as a confidential informant you're
like I'm so and so I'm for example like
I'll roll up on a drug dealer this is
like the classic example but we'll
continue to let you sell some like side
weed but they knowingly in their own
files have allowed over 5 000 crimes to
be committed this is the this is nuts
what's the guy the famous uh gangster
from Boston
the whole thing he wasn't informant the
whole time so he was able to push
but I bet that they do that with a lot
of people and to a certain extent I
wonder if it's more valuable
okay but again to buy weed or something
but the ant they should have to answer
for that is what I'm saying is that
there's no accountability on this they
don't go before Congress and like these
are the number of crimes that we've been
allowed these are what the crimes were
you know what I really enjoyed was that
episode you guys did with uh Johnny
Mitchell yeah the drug guy yes
fascinated guy yes um and he had a point
about El Mayo like the cartel boss
they're like yeah he is the guy because
clearly he's in on it with the DEA yeah
and he's like he's never been arrested
before that nobody knows where he is
yeah he's like no we just let him exist
he's the Kingpin because at least we can
talk every once in a while he's like
yeah the Tijuana cartel is over there
like oh those guys who are chainsawing
people's heads off yeah they're right
yeah and it's all just like like yeah
but he's also and you basically he's
criminal in his own right you just want
quality control where it's like they
have to go and say okay well we allowed
this guy to do this exactly sell x
amount of drugs but he got this many but
he got this guy arrested who sold but I
have to make this case to people and
they don't my point is is that they have
been effectively they were given the
greatest gift of all time after 9 11.
they were given carte blanche more money
and effective legal Immunity on breaking
what previously would have been the law
it's been over 20 years they have less
approval than in I think modern American
history for federal law enforcement
since like the church Committee of the
1970s and there's no like serious effort
to rein it in and why not like there
should be we can agree that BLM and Jan
6 were both obviously infiltrated we
just never scared about their victories
that's the thing we never hear about
this awarded attacks that's what they
say there's no proof likewise Nasser
molest 236 they knew the whole time I
mean they were tipped off faculty
administrators how many I I I mean crazy
I don't know exactly like they got
multiple complaints he molested I think
at least 100 girls or something like
that in the time period when he was
first reported as to when the F and by
the way in that case too the FBI agent
was actively who was actively trying to
get job at USA Gymnastics while he was
supposed to be investigating the case
wow there's no way that he's going to be
objective of course he's trying to get
hired by the people who's [__]
investigating holy [__] look at this
yeah not gonna face charges that's the
other thing he didn't even uh he didn't
even it was never held to account
they're like there are so many little
girls who were molested because of this
man yeah they can go on forever like
there's like yeah the the five dozen
crimes thing which I love Whitey Bulger
is a great example as well I think FBI
and Jan six but I mean even the Trump
stuff I mean some of the things that
came out for fisa for example you're
like this is all you need to just get a
warrant